ragazzi stavo pensando una cosa visto
che siamo qui tutti insieme riuniti no
perché non facciamo l'albero di natale?
si dai no però scusate un attimo ragazzi ma che giorno è oggi 18 novembre ma perché scusa?
no dirmi che sei uno di quelli che vuole
fare l'albero nelle date precise é proprio
una roba antica l'albero lo fa quando te lo senti voi ce l'avete lo spirito natalizio certo é
arrivato facciamolo ragazzi ma visto che
siamo tutti insieme no riuniti perché
non facciamo l'albero di natale? ma
scusami mary ma che giorno è oggi dai il 3 dicembre
no ragazzi come da tradizione l'albero
si fa l'8 dicembre l'Immacolata
ragazzi siamo a Milano e a milano
l'albero si fa il 7 il giorno di Sant'Ambrogio
ma dai é il suo albero siamo a casa sua aiutiamola visto che siamo tutti insieme mi
sembra carino facciamola contenta dai
e rompiamo sta tradizione secolare va bene
no io mi rifiuto
dai ragazzi animo su é bello fare
l'albero ripassiamo un attimo i ruoli
allora giorgi tu sarai l'addetto all''apertura dei rami mi raccomando eh
tutti questi buchi non ci devono essere
belli aperti belli pomposi tu invece ti
occuperai delle lucine ma che palle amore é bellissimo mettere le luci all'albero di
Natale dai e invece edo che ha un
bellissimo senso artistico si occuperà
delle palline quindi i ruoli sono
definiti tutto chiaro? possiamo iniziare?
scusa tu cosa fai?
io mi occupo della playlist musicale
volete avere un bel sottofondo musicale
mentre fate l'albero? ci pensa marina ci
vediamo dopo ragazzi ciao ma che palle
allora ragazzi ripassiamo velocemente
anche se so che siete già molto
preparati prima le lucine poi le
palline ma mi raccomando sotto quelle
più grandi e sopra quelle piccole esatto iniziamo subito!
ma cosa stai facendo Marina cos'è sta
roba?
siete andati via e mi sono portata
avanti ha iniziato a mettere le palline
ma certo siamo andati a prendere
le lucine vanno prima queste ma chi l'ha detto?
ma se io non so cioé se io non posiziono prima le palline come faccio a sapere poi dove
ma perché le stai mettendo lí? ma no
ma prima vanno quelle grosse in basso e
poi alla fine in alto ma chi l'ha deciso?
ma siete proprio fiscali! togli dai toglile
ragazzi comunque per questo Natale
avevo pensato a una cosa super carina da
fare praticamente dopo aver messo tutte
le palline ognuno di noi scrive dei
bigliettini dentro i bigliettnii scriviamo
dei nostri desideri e poi quando apriremo
i regali tutti insieme leggeremo i
bigliettini cercando di capire a chi
appartiene il desiderio mariiiinaa ma
cos'è sta roba? allora perché non appendi
i biscotti di pan di zenzero e lasci la
tazza per babbo natale marina cresci un pó!
vabbè comunque siete proprio cattivi
sta venendo perfetto allora ragazzi mi
raccomando riempiamolo tutto non
lasciamo spazi il dietro deve essere come il davanti non facciamo
differenze l'albero deve essere equilibrato
e perfetto su ogni lato
bravissimi a proposito intravedo un
piccolo spazio dietro riempiamolo subito!
ragazzi stavo pensando una cosa se non
mettiamo palline dietro non si offende
nessuno no? ci concentriamo qui mettiamo tutte le palline più belle qui quelle un
pó meno carine ai lati dietro vuoto
perfetto di qua va bene dai perfetto
sono state veramente le vacanze di Natale più belle della mia vita! Ma Domenica? La sciita di
Domenica! Fantastica! Ci siamo veramente divertiti
anzi mi dispiace proprio separarmi da
voi peró adesso che ci penso...
se facessi una bella cioccolata calda e
mi aiutate a smontare l'albero stiamo
ancora un pó insieme no? Si dai ci sta! Volentieri!
Comunque sono state delle vacanze di Natale bellissime no?
Si beh più o meno sei stata sempre al
telefono! Ho capito ma io non so sciare
la regina del bob e poi tu dormi di
sempre io? Si e mi devi anche restituire il mio
maglione te lo ridaró comunque stavo pensando se faccio una bella cioccolata calda e
mi aiutate a smontare dai ragazzi ma aiutatemi un attimo in tre si fa piú in  fretta!